[Musique]
jacques charon il semble que la reine
d'angleterre est un goût assez prononcé
pour feydeau c'est exact c'est
absolument exact et non seulement la
reine mais je crois aussi toute la
famille royale car voilà trois fois que
nous aurons fait dos quand nous venons à
londres jouer à londres et à chaque
feydeau que nous avons joué un membre de
la famille royale étaient présents la
reine mère la princesse et d'hier il y
avait quatre représentants de la famille
royale parce qu'il avait sa majesté la
reine le duc d'edimbourg et le prince
charles et la princesse anne et je crois
que le prince charles particulièrement
et est heureux de venir car la reine m'a
avoué que le prince charles était fou de
théâtre de musique et de théâtre
parce que après la représentation un
super oui nous avons été présentés à la
reine à l'ambassade de france
le souper à et lieu et après le souper
la reine à désirer voir chaque chaque
acteur de la comédie française qui nous
a procuré l'occasion fait un grand
plaisir et l'honneur de bavarder avec la
reine et le duc et nous on parlait
beaucoup de feydeau puisque maintenant
feydeau devient un auteur franco anglais
il avait joué le feydeau voilà une
quinzaine d'années mais depuis deux ans
trois ans ils attendent les troubles la
troupe française lui française avec du
feydeau et eux-mêmes ont inscrit leur
répertoire du théâtre national la puce à
l'oreille donc halals vic c'est laurence
olivier soeur laurence olivier et cette
pièce que j'ai mis en scène
voilà plusieurs fois que nous venons
enfin deux fois et monsieur petit dôme
unis qui est l'organisateur justement de
ce world season nous a demandé de
revenir le plus vite possible c'est à
dire j'espère l'année prochaine et
devenir beaucoup plus longtemps que
cette fois ci nous restons seulement une
semaine nous jouerons deux spectacles et
il aimerait l'année prochaine que nous
venions au moins un mois
[Musique]